I feel so short can you even see me you
see my little head that's good enough I
guess
all right everybody smile all right I
love speaking at colleges I just came
from the University of nevada-reno I
recently spoke of the Washington Policy
Center George Mason University I'll be
going to colleges in New York and
Tennessee I'll be at my alma mater
University of Florida journalism College
go Gators for a student conference about
freedom of information and government
accountability the conference we're
putting on is funded with some of the
proceeds from stonewalled I'm pleased to
have heard from quite a few journalism
college professors not hundreds but a
few who say that they've added
stonewalled to the recommended reading
for the journalism students or in the
case of a Florida professor that wrote
me a letter last week I wrote me an
email
he said he scrapped their textbook and
is replaced it with Stonewall and I'm
really pleased to hear that they some
journalism college professors think
there's something of teachable value in
there and I love learning about the
colleges that I visit one of the
interesting facts about Hillsdale which
you all probably know but I found
interesting is the fact that it turned
down the invitation to the Tangerine
Bowl in the 1950s for its undefeated
football team because hills dales black
players weren't going to be allowed on
the field that's standing for principle
so thank you so much for inviting me
in 2009 President Barack Obama pledged
to make history with a high level of
transparency his administration would
bring to government he issued a federal
directive stating in part here's a quote
my administration is committed to
creating an unprecedented level of
openness in government we will work
together to ensure the public trust and
establish a system of transparency
public participation and collaboration
openness will strengthen our democracy
and promote efficiency and effectiveness
in government it sounds so good in
theory the Clinton years had proven
difficult for the cause of transparency
and any hopes that George W Bush would
usher in a new era of openness were
quickly dashed for reporters like me but
Barack Obama here he was placing a value
and emphasis on openness that really to
us at least in this business set him
apart it could only mean positive things
for journalists especially for
investigative journalists like me whose
effectiveness as watchdogs of government
is directly proportional to our ability
to access public information and inside
sources at least that's what we thought
but the Obama administration has found
itself instead making history for its
secrecy and assaults on the press
there's delay denial obstruction
intimidation retaliation bullying
surveillance and for some the possible
threat of criminal prosecution in my
view and that of other national
reporters this is proving to be the
least transparent administration we've
covered it's so bad that practically
every major news outlet including the
CBS News Washington Post in The New York
Times
signed a scathing letter to the White
House in 2013 objecting to unrestricted
restrictions on the press that are
unprecedented that we have not dealt
with before we wrote quote as surely as
if they were placing a hand over a
journalist camera lens officials in this
administration are blocking the public
from having an independent view of
important functions of the executive
branch of government
we called some Obama administration
press policies in this letter quote
arbitrary restraint and unwarranted
interference on legitimate news
gathering activities and we told the
White House you are in effect for
placing independent photojournalism with
visual press releases we said the White
House behavior raised constitutional
concerns New York Times photographer
Doug Mills like in the White House press
office to the Soviet news agency Tass
it's so bad that in 2013 the Free Press
advocacy group reporters without borders
gave a serious downgrade to America's
standing in the global free press
rankings rating the Obama administration
as worse than Bush's quote the
whistleblower is the government's enemy
wrote the group quite rightfully
explaining its findings it said amid an
all-out hunt for leaks and sources 2013
will be the year of the Associated Press
scandal which came to light when the
Department of Justice acknowledged it
had seized the news agencies phone
records and they weren't the only ones
complaining in March of 2014 New York
Times reporter James risin spoke at an
investigative journalism conference I
attended at Berkeley and called the
Obama administration quote the greatest
enemy of press freedom in at least a
generation perhaps the best example I
can think of as to how this
administration threatens loss of access
to control its public message is a
little story that I tell about c-span in
summer of 2010 c-span wanted to add
footage of President Obama to a White
House documentary that it produced in
the final years of the George W Bush
administration so President Obama agreed
to tape a brief interview in the Oval
Office with Brian lamb the founder and
executive chairman of c-span's board of
directors the nine minute interview
conducted with both men standing is
pretty innocuous what have you changed
in this room Brian lamb asks the
president in the Oval Office we have not
redecorated yet answers the president
given that we are in the midst of some
very difficult economic times we decided
to hold off last year in terms of making
some changes
all as well until about two weeks later
when a c-span official gets a call from
Obama's director of broadcast media dag
Vega Vega tells c-span that in just a
couple of days The Washington Post will
be breaking the story of the president's
reported multi-million dollar renovation
of the Oval Office Vega is calling to
make sure that c-span won't follow up
that news by running its interview with
the president that seemed to imply the
opposite the one that was taped just
days before quote you're going to save
the interview for the documentary which
was set to air in a few weeks right Vega
reportedly asked the c-span official if
the public were to see the president's
interview at that time they might wonder
whether he had been clueless or had
intentionally perhaps been misleading
about the impending makeover from
c-span's viewpoint this is a problem
there was never in agreement as to when
the president's interview would air and
it would be foolish for c-span to hold
the relevant material only to air the
inaccurate interview later for the
documentary
so discussions go back and forth with
the White House saying that the
agreement was for the president's
interview to air in the future around
the release of the updated documentary
but with the news events c-span
rightfully decides it has no choice but
to air the interview sooner when the
story breaks about the Oval Office
decorations the White House follows up
by pressuring c-span to change its mind
and suggest that the cable television
network will be punished with lack of
access if they do air the interview on
August 31st that year as the White
House's Vega had foretold the Washington
Post breaks the news so the president's
Oval Office facelift c-span goes ahead
and airs the president's interview the
same day that night Josh earnest then
White House deputy press secretary now
White House press secretary reportedly
fires off an angry email to c-span the
biggest surprise is that he sends it in
the middle of the president's live
address to the nation about the drawdown
of US troops from Iraq you'd think he'd
have bigger fish to fry in the email
ernest accuses c-span of being
egregiously unethical and violating term
of the interview though there's no
evidence of any existence of any prior
agreement he continues to insist the
White House would not and did not agree
to an interview with the president
without specifying all the terms under
which it would air Ernest went on to say
that no other news organization has done
such a thing to the Obama White House
and he threatens to withhold future
access for its part frustrated c-span
officials feel they're the ones who have
been wronged after all the president is
the one who gave an interview containing
incorrect information in which the
content was almost immediately
invalidated like a bad-tempered child
stomping his foot against the exercise
of logic and reason ernest accuses
c-span of a violation of trust and says
they'll be unlikely to see any further
cooperation for the president as long as
he remains in office one can only guess
whether the Obama White House has made
good on that threat to withhold
cooperation but c-span's programming
since that date reflects no interview
with either the President or the first
lady the message don't cross the White
House even if it involves the simple act
of airing an on-the-record on-camera
unedited interview with the President of
the United States the consummate public
official the White House gets to direct
its coverage and the terms good behavior
will be rewarded with access dissenters
will be punished and I hate to say it
but I think many news organizations
would have agreed to the White House
demand to hold the president's interview
no questions asked President Obama seems
to be either oblivious or in denial or
maybe he just thinks the repeating the
same thing often enough will make people
believe it to be true during an internet
question-and-answer session hosted by
Google On February 14th 2013 the
president told the online audience this
is the most transparent administration
in history every visitor that comes into
the White House is now part of the
public record every law we pass every
rule we implement we put online for
everyone to see
the Obama administration measures it's
supposed transparency accomplishments by
the sheer number of documents published
online and the amount of paper turned
over to come
on Benghazi the president says we've had
more testimony and more paper than ever
before never mind all the paper they're
withholding the ignored and denied
Freedom of Information Act requests or
the fact that they still refuse to
answer many basic questions more than
two years later the job of getting at
the truth has never been harder and in
part it's because the Obama
administration and government in general
have figured out how to avoid questions
and accountability by cutting out the
news media middleman White House
officials have exploited non news media
to spoon-feed unfiltered messaging at
times pure propaganda into the public's
mouth the Google sponsored chat that I
mentioned that came with a pre-selected
audience and questions submitted in
advance via the White House's own
YouTube channel that's the way they like
it they generate their own content rely
on surrogates to help spread partisan
blogs Twitter and Facebook give lots of
interviews to entertainment programs
digital media and feature press and when
they feel the situation demands an
appearance of nusiness such as a
presidential apology for health care
Gove's disastrous launch and obfuscation
over it they look for a soft landing
with a hand-picked outlet and reporter
all of this impacts how well-informed we
can keep the public but also it impacts
the very survival of investigative
journalism in the three decades of
polling by the Pew Research Center four
people in the press news organizations
are near all-time lows when it comes to
the public's view of our accuracy
fairness and independence but there's
one thing the public still values the
most and it makes no difference whether
they're Democrat Republican or
independent they overwhelmingly support
the media's role as government watchdogs
that support rose a full 10 percents
percentage points from 2011 to 2013 amid
revelations about government conducted
surveillance of the public and the press
the pew poll also reflects the public's
rising concern about loss of civil
liberties if the press doesn't challenge
and expose government
secrecy and overreach then who can so
back to the broken promise of
transparency one of Obama's first
actions in office was to direct federal
agencies to begin complying with Freedom
of Information Law what a concept no
matter where you stand politically as a
journalist one had to be excited by the
idea that under Obama we would gain back
a major necessary tool to do our jobs
Obama said that federal agencies were to
err on the side of releasing public
information rather than withholding it
instead we've seen the opposite a
continuation and expansion of the
federal bureaucracy that perverts FOIA
law as its called
into a tactic used to prevent the
release of public information to send
requests to the end of a bureaucratic
queue that may never be answered and if
it is takes months or years successfully
delaying and obfuscating past the point
of relevance I'm still waiting for
lawful responses to my FOIA requests on
Benghazi Ebola a mysterious paralyzing
virus fast and furious healthcare.gov
from the FBI
try suing over their lack of proper
response and you find the Department of
Justice not encouraging federal agencies
to abide by the spirit of foil law but
instead providing lawyers to defend the
withholding of information and they use
your tax dollars for the court cases so
there's no downside for them they still
accomplish the obfuscation and delay and
in the end even if the court orders them
to turn over documents there is no
punishment or recourse they may have to
pay the plaintiffs legal fees but they
do that with your tax dollars too it's
not just me and it's not an opinion it's
a fact and a consensus in late June 2013
I'm flying back from an investigative
reporters conference in San Antonio
Texas and then seated next to another
journalist Lynn Downey he's the former
executive editor of The Washington Post
who had just spoken at our conference he
had told the audience quote the Obama
administration's war on leaks is by far
the most aggressive that I've seen since
the Nixon administration and
go back that far as Downey and I chat
shoulder-to-shoulder on the airplane I
bring up the subject of Edward Snowden I
asked down if it doesn't seem as though
more attention should be focused on the
content of Snowden's claims instead of
only whether he's hiding whether he
broke the law whether he graduated from
high school Downey agrees four months
later
Downey published what I see is the
definitive report for the Committee to
Protect Journalists it establishes the
Obama administration as the news media's
top choice for least transparent
American presidency in modern times when
you think of all the transparency
promises it's pretty stunning to read
the actual experiences of national news
reporters not those working at
conservative outlets but journalists
from the New York Times The Washington
Post David sang our chief Washington
correspondent of the time said quote
this is the most closed control-freak
administration I've ever covered times
public editor Margaret Sullavan quote
it's turning out to be the
administration of unprecedented secrecy
and unprecedented attacks on a Free
Press Financial Times correspondent
Richard McGregor covering this White
House is pretty miserable in terms of
getting anything of substance to report
on in what should be a much more open
system ABC News White House
correspondent and Compton he's the least
transparent of the seven presidents I've
covered in terms of how he does his
daily business
Josh Gerstein of Politico if the story
is basically one that they don't want to
come out they won't even give you the
basic facts
Washington correspondent Josh Meyer
there is across the board hostility to
the media they don't return repeated
phone calls and emails they feel
entitled to and expect supportive media
coverage post managing editor Kevin
meridian Baretta describes what he sees
as the White House's hypersensitivity
saying that officials often call
reporters and editors to complain about
the tiniest thing maybe something on
Twitter or a headline on a website I
have a slightly different interpretation
of the administration's sensitivities
and all their reactions it's not really
that they're so sensitive
they're simply executing a well thought
out strategy to harass reporters and
editors at the slightest air of
negativity so is to impact the next news
decisions to provide so much unpleasant
static and interference that we may
subconsciously alter the way we report
stories to consume so much of our time
explaining and justifying what we've
reported that we begin to self-censor in
the future they accuse us of quote
piling on when all we're doing is
accurately covering their actions in the
outcome of their decisions but what
human being doesn't instinctively learn
to avoid negative unpleasant feedback
this trend did not begin with the Obama
administration and I'm afraid will not
end there either I don't really blame
the Obama administration and I don't
even blame the entrenched federal
bureaucracy I blame us the news media
when government invariably attempts to
advance itself separate itself from the
public it works for covets information
feathers its own nest and acts as if
it's an independent corporation beholden
to shareholders politicians and special
interests rather than the public it's
the media that's supposed to make sure
that doesn't get out of balance we
haven't been doing a very good job we
send letters we make statements but
instead of insisting our rights be
respected we place ourselves in an
unnecessarily unnecessarily subservient
position as if it's a favor we're asking
for something to be granted at the
King's pleasure rather than a right that
were entitled to instead of demanding
the government follow the law we
politely and somewhat timidly ask could
you pretty please follow the law instead
of demanding access to information we
own that's collected on our behalf by
public servants paid with tax dollars we
make an appeal could you maybe please
just consider giving us some of our
information and here I'd like to pause
and take some questions on this topic
before speaking a little bit on a
related topic how the government
generates its own propaganda using your
tax dollars and why what you see on the
news is so homogeneous and often
discourages a very
regional reporting they would actually
get more viewers so we'll take questions
for a few minutes and then I'll talk
about that there's some nice young
ladies in the aisles ready to hear from
you yes sir thank thank you very much
quick question it seems to me part of
the problem seems to be that we do not
have a loyal opposition anywhere in this
government relative to what the people
want in demand about Liberty well I
would say there is a viewpoint a shared
viewpoint among a lot of people that
even the Republican quote opposition is
not doing its best job at presenting
opposing viewpoints and I will say that
I've noticed this is just my opinion
based on observations but also
conversations with staffers and members
of Congress like the media there seems
to be less will to do oversight to do
the tough ask the tough questions and do
the follow through much like the media I
hear staffers and members of Congress
saying the same sorts of things there
just isn't the appetite and the
leadership to do tough oversight they
want to take the easy road they do look
into things but only go so far and then
they seem not to follow up so I've made
some of those same observations and I
feel like there's some symmetry with
what's gone on in some aspects with the
media as well
I'll let the lady with the monthlies
with the microphones decide who goes can
you shed some light or give us some
insight and why the Obama administration
is so untransparent do they have things
to hide or they just constitutionally
not inclined to shed any information on
what they're doing give us some insight
into that please it's hard to know what
people are hiding when they don't tell
you what they're hiding but I would
argue it's a natural inclination of
those in power to do that I believe when
President Obama said he was going to
usher in a new era of transparency I
believe he meant it I believe he thought
he could and something happens along the
way whether it's embarrassing
information they'd rather not have be
released or they get in and data by
advisers who have different opinions but
it seems to be that no matter how good
the intentions are the opposite happens
but that's where again as I said I fault
the press if that's the natural
inclination of government it's our job
is the media to push back against that
and make sure it's not successful if
they're withholding information that
they shouldn't be withholding we're
supposed to dig and probe and push on
that and I don't think we've always done
the best job at that
um you know I just want to follow up on
this gentleman's question because it was
kind of what I was thinking originally
but what I'm concerned about is this
president has made so many decisions
that really are not in the best
interests of the United States and
that's what concerns me that's what he's
hiding
Benghazi the national security I mean
it's just all of his decisions lead me
to think there's something very nasty
going on as a journalist when someone
doesn't want to tell you something
especially when it's arguably public
information that's what sets off the
idea that they're wanting to hide
something for a reason even if you don't
know what it is but that's certainly
what keeps you going in my case what
keeps me digging on the other hand I
would say there's still about 50% of
America that would disagree with you and
I have a very active social media
account and for all the people who say
who sound exactly like you
I have postings from reasonable
acquaintances who say quite the opposite
who think that and you've heard it too
they still think this president is
correct and what he's done that the
mistakes and problems are overblown by a
partisan press and by Republicans stoke
controversies and so on so I guess
there's this difference of opinion on
that
thank you very much you mentioned that
there was less will to new oversight no
appetite they want to take the easy road
I assume you're talking about the
individual journalists in this case and
that that's certainly the symptoms but
I'm wondering a little deeper if you
could give us your thought on the
corporation influence on each of those
journalists within CBS ABC NBC you name
them all the three letters you see some
of them coming out you see yourself
coming out I see Fox News coming out but
everybody else takes the low road the
high road if you will and stays away
from the real problem why does the
corporation's allow that when I talk
about taking the path of least
resistance I don't particularly mean the
individual ground-level journalists I
think I'm speaking more and I'll talk
about this in a few minutes about the
gatekeepers who decide what goes on TV
and how much headache they want to have
against these highly sophisticated
fairly recent pushback campaigns that
are well-funded that are mounted by
special interests and corporate
interests against news stories they
don't like and news outlets that bother
to publish these things and
whistleblowers who dare to tell the
truth and politicians who dare to ask
the tough questions they're subjected to
an organized campaign to controversial
eyes them funded by PR efforts that are
invisible so it appears to be a
grassroots well over swelling of opinion
that's not really there I call it an
artificial reality but it's somewhat
overwhelming to the news organizations
at times who see all the social media
activity and read the blogs and read
about themselves and maybe don't have
the stomach to push through that it's
hard to say how much corporate influence
there is there's always been a little
bit of that and journalists from time to
time have to push back against what we
feel may be corporate influence but you
don't always know what's corporate what
corporate influence is because you know
one tells you necessarily why certain
decisions are made in a few instances in
the book I talked about I
have some insight because somebody says
something very pointed but in general
you don't always know why the
gatekeepers don't want a particular
story that seems so obvious you know
obviously in the public interest so I
would say corporate corporations and
government have become so intertwined in
their interests and they become
intertwined also with the media which is
beholden to in some respects the
interests of the government and some
corporations as well as whether their
advertisers or some other interests it's
all melding into sort of one big
interest and when they all start to
think alike and don't want to do
oversight on each other because they're
beholden to the same ideas or interests
I think that's part of part of a trend
you might be seeing thank you so much
Sharon I was wondering if you could
perhaps compare the relationship between
Obama's administration and the press
with perhaps past presidents like say
President Woodrow Wilson or Abraham
Lincoln even I don't have an answer for
that question I'm sorry because I'm not
a student of of those times
and I can't say every press has it's
every chunk of press has its own
relationship with the president and
there have always been adversarial
questions asked I think back to Sam
Donaldson hold on mr. president
and there are still reporters asking
adversarial questions even if they don't
make it on the evening news necessarily
every night but I'm sorry I haven't
studied back that far
within the context of what you just said
about a lot of reasons for skepticism
about corporate America and the
government previously you commented that
you gave Obama the benefit of the doubt
when he said he would be transparent
what's the basis of that opinion once he
was already elected to make that be a
key Proclamation as you enter office
without any reason for having to say so
once you're already elected but to focus
so much attention on that I do give the
benefit of the doubt I could be wrong
but my my instincts say he meant it he
thought maybe that was one thing that he
could change about Washington that was a
problem it didn't turn out that way and
I can't tell you what was what's really
in his mind or his heart that's just my
interpretation
hi my name is Dave Ferguson and I'm just
wondering if you know for sure whether
or not this President had his college
record sealed and it's so wouldn't that
be a clear indication of how transparent
this guy was going to meet I have not
looked into that issue sorry I'm going
to try not to answer questions I don't
know anything you know don't know much
about and there if you don't mind let me
go on to the second half of what I
thought you might find interesting to
talk about and then I'll take some more
questions after that okay so this this
gets to the heart of a few questions you
all just asked in the last decade or
more the government has adopted and
perfected many of the public relations
and crisis management strategies
employed by big corporations it's a
natural outgrowth of their incestuous
relationship the big difference is the
government is using your tax dollars to
promote itself and advance its
propaganda one way they do it is by self
producing videos and building their very
own television production facilities
where the upper echelon gives interviews
and speeches controlling everything from
content to lighting while the nation
descended and unprecedented debt
Congress and the federal agencies
ranging from health and human services
to the National Institutes of Health use
millions of your tax dollars to build or
expand their very own television studios
the Food and Drug Administration's
facility boasts quote a number of mobile
and fixed sets as well as various
configurations to allow for a studio
audience of over a hundred the
Transportation Security Administration
TSA sports a studio with Hitachi
high-definition cameras and fujinon
lenses and LCD based teleprompters and
when top officials from those federal
agencies appear on camera naturally they
have to look good so your tax dollars
may kick in for the cost of their hair
stylists makeup artist and wardrobe
consultants when insider told me that
the head of a federal agency even had
her fashion colors analyzed at taxpayer
expense
addition the Pentagon has its own
24-hour channel which features military
news interviews with top defense
officials and programs such as the grill
sergeants while the Pentagon frets over
sequestration cuts of the troops listen
to talk of cutting their pensions your
tax dollars are paying to produce
programs such as a cooking show
competition that features mess-hall
cooks and aides two generals battling it
out over dishes like seared ahi tuna and
lamb with blueberry wine sauce both the
Defense Department and the Centers for
Disease Control provide taxpayer-funded
advisors to television and Hollywood
entertainment producers to promote
accuracy or propaganda depending on your
viewpoint some of the Public Interest
justification for use of these assets
are dubious in 2013 you may remember
Congress caught the IRS making Star Trek
and Gilligan's Island parody videos to
educate federal employees at a
conference when Secretary of Energy
Steven Chu resigned from the Obama
administration the federal agency
produced a slick photo tribute to him
using your money it touts choose
incredible successes but forgets to
mention any of his scandals such as the
failed effort at playing venture
capitalists with tax dollars and green
energy investments like Solyndra and by
its own admission the Pentagon's film
liaison office gives for-profit
filmmakers free use of taxpayer assets
from tanks to jets but only if the film
portrays the images the Pentagon wants
if not the assets are withheld there was
a documentary called Hollywood and the
Pentagon a dangerous liaison in the
documentary they said quote scripts are
cut and sometimes watered-down
characters are changed and historical
truth sometimes fudged one director
might be loaned combat ships and jets
another director whose script displeases
the government or the army may be
refused any kind of support few Great
War films have escaped the influence or
even the censure of the US Army it's
pure propaganda according to the
documentary and you're paying for it
like big corporations each federal
agency in all 535 members of Congress
have teams of taxpayer-funded media and
communications specialists to advance
their message a few years ago a well
placed inside earth US Department of
Agriculture confessed to me that even he
was surprised to learn that his own
agency supposedly had more than 1,200
employees working in some sort of media
relations capacity nationwide Department
of Agriculture 1,200 media relations
employees your tax dollars pay for their
salaries but many times the little more
than private publicity agents for their
bosses spinning avoiding and obfuscating
is expertly as any of their corporate
counterparts and too often we let them
get away with it too often press
releases that read like propaganda from
government and corporations are used in
the news without the required critical
examination and analysis and if you're
confused about all the influences behind
what you see on the news and how they
affect the product there's good reason
at times there's a liberal political
bias in mainstream media that tilts
towards stories favoring liberal social
issues and philosophies but there's also
a competing conservative corporate bias
that favor specific companies industries
and paid interests unfortunately the
result isn't an ideal balance of
complete information about the world
it's often a distorted and perplexing
mix the trend has become more
predominant in the last couple of years
as powerful interests have mastered
their methods of influencing us and some
of our managers have embraced the
influence believing they'll keep their
lucrative jobs by going along rather
than resisting the capitulation to
special interest may preserve these news
managers jobs in the short term but in
the big picture I think they're ensuring
a quicker demise of the entire platform
alienating and eroding the audience that
we supposedly serve while the network
evening newscasts bragged that
increasing numbers of people are
watching the total number of television
broadcast network news audience members
compared to that which is available
remains miniscule
many in the public believe we're feeding
them a lot of pablum I've never before
heard so many people say so liberals
conservatives and people who define
themselves as neither so what is the
mysterious process behind the decisions
as to what stories make the news on a
given night some stories are carefully
chosen and edited by a small group of
broadcast news managers because they
serve a specific set of agendas in a
book called manufacturing consent the
author state commercial news
organizations disseminate propaganda on
behalf of dominant private interests in
the government quote the media do not
function in the manner of the propaganda
system of a totalitarian state rather
they permit indeed encourage spirited
debate criticism and dissent as long as
these remain faithfully within the
system of presuppositions and principles
that constitute an elite consensus a
system so powerful is to be internalized
largely without awareness there are
other factors at play many Story topics
are selected by managers who are as I
say producing out of fear and trying to
play it safe playing it safe means
sharing stories that certain other
trusted media have reported first so
there's no perceived risk to us if we
report them to we're not going out on a
limb we're not reporting anything that
hasn't already been reported elsewhere
but it also means we're not giving
viewers a reason to watch us playing it
safe means shying away from stories that
include allegations against certain
corporations charities and other chosen
powerful entities and people the image
of the news media as fearless watchdogs
poised if not eager to pursue stories
that authorities wish to block is often
a false image decisions are routinely
made in fear of the response that the
story might provoke the propagandists
heavy-handed tactics have worked they
don't even have to pick up the phone and
complain about a story some news
managers demonstrate a Pavlov we have
lobbying style avoidance response when
presented with a story that they fear
will bring some negative reaction we are
weak and diffident when we
needn't be many investigative reporters
around the nation are experiencing the
same thing it's a trend longtime in the
award-winning reporter al sunshine
retired from the CBS owned-and-operated
station in Miami the summer before I
left CBS News afterward he made some
similar observations he said because of
the recent lack of support and
commitment front my investigations I
faced an almost daily battle to get the
time to work on my stories and had to
fight harder than ever for airtime
though his brand of investigative
reporting and consumer stories was
wildly popular with viewers sometimes
resulting in new laws being passed and
criminals getting prosecuted he was told
his stories were too negative instead he
was often reassigned to what we called a
of air news coverage he told me
advertisers are dominating news judgment
in news organizations all over the
country the public interest is being
diminished in the interest of corporate
advertisers and lobbyists what's almost
universally accepted as business as
usual in Washington corruption between
lobbyists dollars and political
favoritism is slowly but surely becoming
the norm for many news organizations as
well
says sunshine it might be growing worse
but historical narrative implies there's
always been an element of this condition
avoidance response in the corporate news
world in his 1967 memoir called due to
circumstances beyond our control CBS
News President Fred friendly expressed
discomfort that top management felt over
its star reporter at the time Edward our
Murrow quote during the 1954-55 season
we did a two-part report on cigarettes
and lung cancer and both CBS and CBS
sponsor Alcoa aluminum company felt the
pressures of the tobacco industry which
buys both air time and aluminum foil the
attitude at CBS says this book was why
does Murrow have to save the world every
week in another instance Fred friendly
quoted CBS founder Bill Paley as telling
Edward Armour oh I don't want this
constant stomachache every time you do a
subject these tendencies to sensor
topics that generate objections from
their powerful targets aren't
necessarily spoken or even consciously
addressed those of us who report on
these sorts of subjects are not told
that our stories are undesirable because
they're not safe or because they
challenge powers as sunshine said news
management manipulation is subtle he
says it comes in many forms like
withholding resources such as cameramen
and producers and conveniently dropping
investigative reports from the newscast
when the timing of the show happens to
run too long to fit it in we've figured
it out ironically management's avoidance
response can result in absurd
machinations that inadvertently generate
the very liabilities they're trying to
avoid some of us have boiled it down to
a saying they're often worried about the
wrong things and not worried about the
right things and I'll tell you just one
story that serves as an example during
the time under skittish broadcast show
management my last two years at CBS I
reported a story on a credit card scan
that showed a surveillance video of a
suspect who was caught on camera
allegedly using one stolen card after
another at Target Walmart Macy's night
of the story nor our use of the
surveillance video was precarious in any
sense
the police had publicly released the
video it had already appeared on the
local news the suspect had been
identified and I had run my story
through the CBS legal department for
legal clearance even under the standards
of the current skittish evening news
management this story was safe but just
prior to air the executive producer
views the finished piece in New York and
rings the hotline phone to the
Washington newsroom where I was we can't
show the suspects face she protests why
not I asked she says he hasn't been
convicted of anything I take a breath
the idea that a criminal suspects face
can't be shown on television comes from
someone who lacks the most basic
knowledge of the law I'm having way too
many of these conversations lately
and I know it means she's not going to
listen to me she's scared of the story
nonetheless I patiently explained that
somebody doesn't have to be convicted of
a crime for us to identify him or show
his face under her mistaken idea of the
law arrest mug shots would never be
shown on the news we wouldn't have shown
a Jason's face when he was accused but
never convicted of murder we would have
had identified any criminal suspects
prior to conviction Timothy McVeigh John
Gotti Jack Kevorkian Lorena Bobbitt Tom
DeLay Martha Stewart Michael Jackson
Bernard Madoff the Unabomber Osama bin
Laden these would all be phantom faces
that we wouldn't be allowed to show none
of these stories would have been done if
we were to consistently apply this
executive producers warped view of the
law still she box call his lawyer and
ask for permission to show his clients
face another breath I look at the clock
it's nearly 6 o'clock story set to air
at 6:30 the odds that I'll reach the
suspects public defender and get a yes
from him in the next half hour are
pretty remote but more important the
idea that we would set a precedent by
asking a suspect for permission to use
his image has to rank as one of the more
prosperous suggestions I've ever heard
well we don't need his permission I
reiterate and I doubt he would give it I
wouldn't if I were him okay she says
still sounding unconvinced we hang up
the phone and when within seconds she
sends me a follow-up message telling me
to blur out the suspects face anyway
just was it a little she says with time
ticking I rush back to the editing booth
and break the news to my producer and
our editor you're not going to believe
this I say but she wants us to get
permission for the defendants lawyer to
use his face or else blur it out what
says my producer dumbfounded that's
outrageous the producer makes another
attempt to reach the attorney whom we
tried earlier it's futile at this hour
and we know that if asked he is going to
say no anyway so we go ahead and blur
out the suspects face and refeed the
story to New York to air in some ways
this may not sound like a very big deal
what's the harm in masking a criminal
suspects identity well I know the answer
the executive producers misguided and
capricious
decision has an avoided risk it's
actually created a potential liability
we've now set a precedent that sets us
up for accusations and of bias and
inconsistent treatment when we don't do
the same for the next accused criminal
suspect so this is just one example of
the twisted way sometimes that you get
the news or don't get the news and I'm
happy to take some questions on that
subject or anything else that you want
to ask
we have time for questions okay we have
some time for questions microphones will
be out please raise your hand and stand
up when they come to you and once again
keep the question shorter than the
answer might be we like that
I hate to have to ask this question but
I just wonder if you've ever been
concerned for your personal safety or
your life in pursuing some of the
stories that you pursue thank you for
asking and I don't want to talk about
that but I'm okay thank you and in the
last week or so the president did an
interview with an online blogger a young
woman with bright green lipstick and it
was heralded by some as a new era of
journalism I was just wondering to what
what do you think the this
administration's target audiences are
for their release of information well as
I described I think this administration
has perfected the idea of going around
neutral news reporters who would ask
critical questions and I don't have a
problem with doing that sort of thing if
that's what they want to do my only
problem would be if they do that instead
of also being answerable to those who
could ask the tough and probing and
challenging questions and and hold them
accountable on behalf of the public and
I think sometimes they do more of that
social media and fun stuff and
entertainment celebrity stuff which does
reach an audience because that's how
some people get their news in a way that
they're not asked critical questions or
they don't have an informed interviewer
on these certain controversial topics
doing that instead of doing more of the
other kind I see as a problem because
I'm I'm a traditional journalist but I
don't have a problem with them doing
that if they want to do it in addition
to
which you presented seems like a great
argument for limited government would
you agree what do you mean by limited
government you talked about I think
1,200 people in media for the Department
of Agriculture oh yes a smaller
government and also you get into issues
of crony capitalism smaller government
reduces those opportunities you know one
might say so what's the word on the
street with your brothers and sisters so
to speak with regard to journalism
schools are they a qsr or pushed back
second part why does Fox kill it in the
ratings every period in your opinion
I don't really know about journalism
schools across the board
I've been thankfully exposed to some
great ones and had dinner sitting next
to one here from Hillsdale who's trying
to teach who are trying to teach
students good journalism and fair
reporting I think a lot of people go
into this business
maybe not coming from journalism school
sometimes they find their way in through
a friend or a contact they've studied
politics or government but I'll say two
things growing out from that some people
get in the business and they think their
job is to convince you to feel the way
they do about something that's a
different kind of journalism that's not
how I was taught if in the end after
I've presented you with what the facts
are as I've been able to find them I
really don't care what you decide I'm
not here to try to make you think a
certain way I want you to have facts
that you can't get easily somewhere else
and then if you see all those facts and
you don't care or you think the opposite
of other people whatever you think is
fine it doesn't bother me I just like to
put those facts on the table because
those belong to you in my opinion and
you should have those as you make up
your mind some people want to change
your mind but secondly I would also say
believe it or not some of the problems
I've described are not the ground-level
reporters and producers who do a great
job from what I've seen day in and day
out
producing original stories in an
unbiased fashion but there are key
gatekeepers that shape those stories and
decide which stories will go on the air
and which ones will never be seen unless
they're shaped a certain way and that's
more of where I see a problem and what
was your second question oh yeah
Fox News has great ratings they could
probably tell you more about how they
why they resonate but just what I hear
from people who do I know a lot of
people that sample so they watch Fox
they watch MSNBC they click around they
want to hear not just yes people do seek
their own opinions but they also want to
hear what the other people are saying
too and I think a lot it resonates
because maybe it's the only network
that's doing that specifically where
there are several networks doing the
liberal side of it so you can only see
if you want to watch conservative Tilted
talk I would say a lot of the reporting
is very neutral but conservative Tilted
talk and topics I can't think of another
TV station that you can go to so they
get that whole audience in one lump sum
while the rest of the networks divide up
the liberal tilting audience that's my
guess wait advise would you get to
pressure journalists and how has the
increased speed of the internet and the
use of social media impacted
investigative and analytical journalism
I don't have general advice for
journalists you'd have to ask me a
question about what kind of journalism
and I'm sorry what question whatever you
advice you're looking for the impact of
social media has been tremendous I think
some of it good some of it bad you can't
unwind and go back from the internet I
think some people wish you could
bloggers for example a mixed blessing
there have been bloggers that have
uncovered amazing stories that the news
media hasn't but by the same token you
have to sit there and sift and filter
and be exposed to a lot of stuff that
may not be true to get to the truth and
I don't have any magic recipe because
I've been asked to help you figure
out as we try to do where is there a
source that you can believe where can
you go and you don't have to knock
20% off because it's a conservative site
or 30% off what they say because it's a
liberal site it's very confusing time
and I don't know what's going to be born
next something will come of all of this
and I hope it's something good down the
road but I can't unfortunately I can't
foresee what what's next yeah we
remember MIT economist Jonathan Gruber
who wrote Obamacare with with full
understanding that the American people
want to be lied to and he did could it
be that Obama also believed that we are
all idiots that want to be lied to it's
hard to say what conversations are had
and what they think but the evidence is
clear with healthcare.gov and has not
been well reported in my view by some it
has been but not widely reported I have
reported this at CBS News and afterwards
the projections showed prior to this
passing the government's own projections
show that millions of people were going
to be knocked off their health insurance
the millions of people are going to be
knocked off of their work insurance this
is happening now and that's not being
widely reported being I think
overshadowed by positive news I really
have no explanation for how the
government's professions as to what was
going to happen are so different from
what the documentary record shows they
knew was going to happen but they are
very much at odds there's that's not an
opinion that's a fact
thank you so much for your time this
evening my question is going to go back
to when you talked about how it's
important for us to be able to make
proper decisions to have all the
information really in front of us that
you have transparency that organizations
like the sunlight foundation have been
very adamant advocating my question is
going to lend towards campaign finance
and we see a lot of times where
politicians oftentimes aren't able to
disclose their information to the public
and my question to you would be what
does freedom of the press have to do
with campaign finance and how that would
relate to an electoral system that we
have in the United States today
thank you that may be a little bigger
question than I'm qualified to answer
but I would say every time you get at
the heart of campaign finance what's
wrong with it how to get influence out
of it they've thought of another way
around that and one big area I'll just
give us an example even if you regulate
full transparency and where certain
donations come from and limits on
campaign contributions and everything
you try to do people can't go straight
from Congress to lobbying without a
cooling-off period there are new tools
that come into play they allow them to
get around all of that and one tool I
think that's being widely used I've
reported a little bit on it our
nonprofits which are highly in my view
unregulated from the sense of the IRS
looking at what they really do and what
they have to disclose financially
nonprofits are often co-opted by special
interests because they sound like
altruistic sort of neutral organizations
but in fact the strings for them are
being pulled and they're being funded by
special interests who are in some way
benefiting in some cases a member of
Congress for example and I did a story
on a couple of years ago Republican
congressman who started what I would
call a fake charity that was supposed to
collect money for scholarships
educational scholarships but hadn't
given out any and he probably never
thought his own connection with this
charity would be revealed and it was
only revealed through a strange set of
circumstances but once it was revealed
he was connected to this charity that
was collecting millions of dollars from
guess who all the interest regulated by
the committee that he sits on
tobacco industry pharmaceutical industry
and he was golfing and giving access to
the people donating millions of dollars
to the charity which employed his family
members but gave out no scholarships and
this kind of this trail went on and on
this was a way I believe the money was
started for that foundation by a
pharmaceutical company after which this
congressman introduced favorable
legislation and made statements on the
floor I was able to match up almost
every time he got a large donation from
one of these interests he was supposed
to regulate after a donation or right
before a donation he did he took some
action or made some statement in
Congress and it took a lot of digging to
find that relationship but to me it was
pretty clear he and he resigned from
Congress shortly after that but that's
just one example I think of it's so hard
to find an answer to how to how to get
influence out and and make it be where
people who are elected are serving just
the folks instead of the you know well
financed interests we have time for one
more question thank you for your
insights tonight
supposing I'm a concerned citizen
outside of the profession of journalism
and politics but interested in as much
accuracy and objectivity as I can find I
come home from work with about a half an
hour to an hour of time to invest in
that what wreck American recommendations
would you make to me about how I should
use that time the best I've been talking
about this a lot with people because I
think we all have to develop our own
ways I can't say go to one site and that
site will always have the news that's
probably the way you want it I don't
think that exists and yet many sites and
many news outlets do great reporting
maybe it's harder fought these days but
PBS Frontline 60 minutes the network's
the newspapers they're still doing great
investigative reporting you have to find
reporters you trust maybe on a
particular topic because of some
experience you've had that knows that
it's ringing true and then you may
decide that's a reporter you will follow
on other topics because you found them
to be in your view trustworthy same with
some news outlets I think you'll
hop around from one place to the next
and it's not going to be the same you
just spend your 30 minutes looking at
the same three or four places every time
I just don't think it works that way a
lot of people are telling me that they
use their Twitter feed and Facebook feed
as stories circulating on outlets they
might never have seen they popped
through those and they find stories of
interest and that's sort of their daily
newspaper of the day they're kind of
just looking around and seeing what
people are sending around and talking
about I will repost in the next couple
of days something that I posted a couple
weeks ago because people were asking
with some alternative websites you might
want to check out that do some good
investigative journalism you may not
like everything they do but they do some
great work and just as one example I'll
say Project Censored you can find
probably Project Censored calm but you
can google it they've made it their
mission to take stories that are
untouchable that news outlets for
whatever reason for a variety of reasons
don't want to touch and they they report
on those and at the end of the year they
compile I think the ten best stories
into a book and publish it but these are
stories you probably won't see anywhere
else for a lot of different reasons in
there there are places like that that
you might find interesting
so I'll repost that the next week or so
in sharyl Attkisson comm and you can see
if there's anything of interest there
for you thank you all
you